[Music]
it's the martre all just for last Comedy
Festival Kevin har presents LOL at jfm
got here last night been uh really doing
it up in the city me and my friends went
out last night trying to meet some
ladies didn't go too well uh you ever
have that friend and you're like going
out to bars trying to meet some girls
nothing happens and your friend goes
screw this let's go to a strip club I
don't get that logic you know that's
like going uh going fishing not catching
anything and being like [__] this let's
go to the
aquarium yeah yeah we walked around the
village a bit uh saw some gays that was
fun uh they had the protesters out there
homophobia what a weird thing huh any
homophobes here
yeah what a weird thing to put your
energy into you know yeah like I did
some shows in Boston recently I was
talking to this guy after the show I
told him about a friend of mine who's
gay this guy goes you have a gay friend
I wouldn't even shake a gay man hand I
was like Jesus Christ why not he goes
you know how many dicks are on that
hand I was like well you shook my hand
you okay with my
dick cuz 's a lot of interaction between
the two all right yeah wow that is
terrible logic you know who else touches
a lot of dicks
women Yeah man they put them all over
you're
[Applause]
screwed
I don't know I think homophobia can
actually be kind of dangerous you know a
friend of mine he's kind of a tough guy
he went skydiving recently he's like
yeah I'm not strapping some guy in my
back that's super gay now he's
dead
yeah I don't
know homophobia I'm not gay I do like
the ladies big fan of the old labia yeah
yeah yeah uh which is weird cuz when I
was a kid I hated girls when I was like
6 years old I thought girls were gross
thought they were dumb you know you're
allowed to hate girls as a kid but
that's really the only group a kid's
allowed to hate you know cuz if I was a
six-year-old that hated Puerto
Ricans that would be weird you know if I
was like hey Mom I hate Puerto Rican she
would never say oh you'll like them one
day you'll like them a
lot hey you guys are a fun group uh some
crowds get so offended by these dumb
jokes you know I had a guy come up to me
after a show once he goes hey buddy I'm
gay and Puerto Rican all right I don't
appreciate those jokes you know my life
is I was like whoa take it easy how hard
your life is dude you have the most
parades how bad could it
be um all right yeah
hey
smattering ah yeah yeah racial stuff
always touchy I'm not racist I look at
racism the same way I look at Nickelback
you know yeah it's fun to joke about but
uh you never want to see it live yeah
right uh yeah I'm doing pretty well I
have h four black friends right now it's
the best I've ever done and uh all my
black friends tell me I'm the whitest
guy they know which um I'm not sure what
that means I guess because I say words
like scadaddle I don't know but yeah um
I don't know maybe I am super white I
think the whitest thing about me is the
fact that after I get a haircut I like
to leave the barber
shop yeah I don't see all the need for
all the hanging around you know you guys
don't do that at a dentist's office you
know you don't get a root canal and gooo
that was great I'm going to sit in the
lobby for 4 hours yeah and I know some
people are like hey buddy that's a
stereotype well they made three movies
about it so you figure it
out yeah um yeah I don't hate any group
you know I try to also try to be a good
feminist you know I'm a good feminist uh
it's tough being a feminist you know cuz
some girls are feminist and some girls
aren't so as a guy how do I know how to
act like some girls you open the door
for them they're like wow a gentleman
than very much other girls you open the
door for them they're like what you
think I can't open my own door I'm like
whoa hey I'm just trying to [__]
you how do I get here
on yeah you gals are a tough nut to
crack you know you're all different you
know like like some girls like a nice
guy some girls like jerks so how do you
know what I do I do both I see an
attractive lady I open the door for her
and I say after you
fatty Mick said up cover your bces you
know keep them guessing yeah all
right cool I uh I go to bars to meet
girls that's my move I notice there's a
lot of girls at the bar these days
flirting with guys just for the free
drinks you know they're not going to put
out but they want those drinks pretty
good move makes you wonder you think
there's ever been any smart kids out
there who would flirt with pedophiles
just for the
candy now you're like hey Timmy don't
talk that guy he's a child molester I
know what I'm
doing yeah got to get these Skittles
somehow all
right half of you are enjoying this half
of you look
terrified these are just jokes calm down
uh they're just words people are [__]
animals these are syllables
um uh cool all right yeah comedy
pedophiles what a creepy group huh yeah
creep creep is a fun word huh cuz it's a
word that changed with age like to a kid
creepy is like a like a haunted house to
an adult creepy is like a guy on a bus
who Winks at you while eating a
banana yeah uh is weed legal here yet
has that happened almost you're getting
there boy I can't wait for weed to be
legal that'll be fun huh CU like I don't
know booze my dad was like an angry
drunk you know but by the time I'm a
father weed's going to be legal we're
going to be the first generation of
parents to be legally hir in front of
our kids how lucky are these kids you
know you can't be an Angry Dad when
you're high you know you're trying to
yell at your son what's that Timmy you
want pancakes for dinner and Cartoon
Network all
night I like the way you
think all right thanks a lot have a good
night thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you